réalité virtuelle hologram caméra 360
degrés la société infinity dream est une
entreprise touche à tout ces start-up
créée en septembre dernier à coignières
par six yvelinois mordus de nouvelles
technologies propose à ses clients de
tester ses produits dernier cri
vous pouvez venir jouer à des jeux
voyager ou visionner des films voir des
scènes de théâtre des animaux il ya
vraiment pas de limites c'est selon vos
envies on peut vous transporter
directement dans un monde virtuel dans
plusieurs univers différent pour tester
ces nouvelles technologies dans ce
temple de l'innovation de 60 m² un
groupe de quatre à six personnes devra
débourser 20 euros pour une heure la
structure organise également des
événements éphémères
on a fait la petite soirée halloween en
une seule on a essayé de faire quelques
thèmes quelques anniversaires
on a eu que des bons retours en
parallèle de son activité de réalité
virtuelle grégory bousseton et son
équipe ont importé du japon le concept
de la lévitation
cette innovation devrait leur permettre
de travailler avec des bijouteries des
boutiques de prêt-à-porter
donc on est obligé de s'adapter vraiment
pour être les meilleurs sur le marché
on a toujours de quoi surprendre même
les professionnels qui sont plus de
vingt ans de métier on arrive à 500 sera
pas demain
la société envisage déjà de développer
un deuxième centre à paris avant de se
tourner vers l'international dans les
prochaines années